foreign
[Music]
ER why he wants this job I need the
money money isn't the reason he wants
his job the salad man killed his son
you don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here to translate actually I'm here to
interpret John you have tallies
approaching
The Interpreter saved my life and now I
have to go save his Ahmed ended up with
a price on his head from the Taliban we
can't intervene I am gonna have to get
him out myself
I'm looking for Ahmed I'll give you a
full set of tools but you're gonna be
alone
you got to adapt this is what you got
I am going to get that man and his
family out
guy Richie's the Covenant rated R in
theaters April 21st
[Music]
foreign